eric tay how are you doing all right rob
we're back at it i guess back at it
another division
beta stream
uh this time around it's open beta yep
anyone can join at least on xbox one
today
yeah currently right yeah currently
eventually uh other ones will probably
open up tomorrow pc and ps4 awesome oh
just one day this time okay
uh yeah but um
reason being another stream is there are
a couple new things that they've added
into the open beta yep uh so there's new
mission that opens up the uh
tech wing uh so you'll see my character
in a second and i have the upgrades you
haven't done that mission so we're gonna
do that mission
yeah i intentionally didn't do it
because i wanted to kind of capture it
fresh yeah it's a fun mission uh and
then the other thing that's uh different
is there's two new high-end weapons in
the dark zone that you can purchase and
then they've done some tweaks to the
dark zones so after we do the mission
we'll check out the dark zone we'll see
if there's more ai like they say they
are and i think the ar or ai excuse me
uh have a little bit more life i think
so a little bit more spongy um and then
like there's other minor changes that we
can talk about in a second but let's go
into the game let's do it and here i am
and i'm waiting on you i am uh
just almost there yeah i'm gonna look at
some of the skills uh while we're
waiting for you yeah so
i ha i have unlocked the modding because
uh i was able to upgrade my medical wing
and my tech wing um the two that you can
mod are you can mod the sticky bomb
which is kind of like that uh launcher
um if you guys noticed from the original
closed beta
now you're able to modify it with the
bfb which increases the damage in the
radius of the explosion
there's the flashbang which you know
obviously does what you know a flashbang
does and then there's proximity fuse um
when it explodes when something walks by
and the other new thing that we didn't
have in the last beta is the sentry or
the turret okay so you can drop this
little mini turret and uh i can why
don't i pick that skill so people can
see it i won't run pulse i guess
um and it's pretty decent for when you
solo play and
also like maybe for extractions or just
to
kind of like
kind of get the ai off you but anyways
let me map out where we're going we're
going to go to that mission
hopefully that's good
yeah let's go to that guy
travel to it do you wanna fast travel to
it sure why not
look it's do i come with you i hope so
you're in my group right
i think i have to do it myself
really i think
no
fast you can't even
i'm in your group i don't know we'll
find out we're almost there this the
wheels are spinning um
also guys if you have questions we'll
try our best to answer them
um did you did you fast travel
i did not is this because i haven't done
it oh wait i can follow you now all
right well i can fast travel to you yeah
fast travel with me that works um i'll
take a look at i haven't gotten any mods
for like the turret oh excuse me yeah i
don't have mods for the turret uh that's
not in the beta oh it's not okay it's
you can't do it it's uh and same with
the heel there's no mod for the heel oh
this time around there is not it's only
the pulse has it always been yeah it's
always been there okay never mind um
it's just because you know given that
it's a beta they they've limited some of
the things oh hey there hi um i don't
have any blue weapons but it'll be fine
uh we're just doing the oh wait do you
have the mission right now
i'm kind of curious because i don't want
to like start this and then like like is
it
not have it like work the mission's
there looks like
d yeah oh replay the mission hold on
yeah you're good that's why it didn't
work there we go
um at least it loads faster hey good
news i just leveled up to level six oh
really yeah just by getting there nice
you'll be of equal level you won't get
wrecked like the guy that was level five
pause
oh he's gonna blow up too
he's still gonna blow up his photos are
so funny it's like
why would you ever wear a flamethrower
hey man they're called the cleaners for
a reason okay they gotta cleanse this
dirty virus
oh shoot
we're going into the flamethrower
wheelhouse
we'll get some more enemies i'll try to
drop down the turret
look at this guy unaware that he's gonna
get his canister oh he's not been
hearing shot oh
then
so what were some of the um i mean i
know we're not going to see them in beta
but like what are some of the uh
other mods for
the turret uh i haven't been able watch
out
i haven't been able to see them oh they
tell you they blocked them yeah they
kind of blur them out they blur out a
bunch of the talents and the perks
canister
oh you got it
they're taking off
yeah right like i got to ditch this
backpack
this propane backpack
this is not pc this is currently xbox
one it's uh the platform that
he's got
also i think i read a gamespot news kind
of like rumorville thing last night that
said that they might be getting dlc
first
oh i did see that yeah so
that'll be interesting to see if that
comes to uh fruition xbox totally a dude
right there what's also going down below
is this a fire pit yeah so there's like
this is like a huge it's called the
morgue um
subway morgue and i think there's like
you'll see a bunch of like caskets
oh this is where they're just dumping
bodies yeah oh that's dark
i'll use my ar so that it's uh you know
more fun for the stream so they can see
people actually getting shot instead of
one-shotting them in the head i'm gonna
use my shotgun oh are you oh oh you got
him i got him there's more guys coming
from there though so watch out yeah
you don't want to be in that
flamethrower wheelhouse
too hot oh here let me try dropping the
uh
yeah yeah get them get them
is it getting them hey dude
it's kind of a slant oh here oh here we
go come on party on there he is
the damage not very good very paltry
he's just
but it did distract him they did
which is good extractions are nice i'm
sure with the mods it'll be better
right
yeah i can imagine
yeah i mean we can we can uh rock
different um
different perks later when we're in the
dz um
yeah unfortunately i didn't get a chance
to like upgrade
the wing yeah you got to do side quests
i did one
yeah i wish i had like
we can go do one if you're closed yeah i
think you only have 240 yeah you can
tell that there are multiple cleaner
teams on site you're looking to burn out
the infection
just like normal be careful well you'll
get the sentry after this so there's
that that's automatic yeah it's part of
the the tech wing gotcha there's totally
dudes over there
oh that guy's there oh that guy's gonna
blow up
oh no he ran oh
is it dark i smell
oh i smell flesh
little barbecue
tasty
good job
have you found any like cool loot areas
i know there's at least one from the
previous mission uh i have not uh so the
interesting two thing too as well is
there's been a couple areas that
have um then again construction in new
york always runs on its own schedule
uh there's been a couple areas that have
been um kind of guarded off by lock
picks
and i don't have any lock picks
oh you do yeah
oh we should have totally opened the
upstairs lock okay we'll go do that
later there's a lock pick upstairs like
from that beginning area
so we are going to like get shot out at
the end of this back up there or
something uh yeah more or less okay they
kind of so
so we still kind of like have a chance
of doing that yeah we could always fast
travel yeah that's cool i want to um try
that out yeah yeah i have come across uh
some like doors that need lock picking
before
yeah you got to loot that other stuff
this relay need that power
uh ayte any big changes from the since a
closed beta so the big changes are this
new mission
as well as uh being able to open up the
tech wing by the way which gives you the
sentry turrets
um
and when you see the dead bodies
get your masks on
these dead bodies oh
that
is
that's kind of dark fun
this is pretty dark that's so dark that
see like the plot the plot of this is
really upsetting like i i dig the
potential story
of this game even though they haven't
really shown a whole lot in the beta but
like it's this is this is [ __ ] watch
out there's totally dudes here
they're cleaning someone right now
oh really i don't know they're burning
something
that or that guy's just pyro dinner time
i don't know but i'm about to shoot this
guy's oh
this is messed up
they were they totally were burning dude
yeah they kicked his body around after
that
they're definitely good
are they you think so
they're just cleaning the street of
vermin man
we're doing you guys a favor
minding this ak
oh did you blow some guy up i did no
such thing well there's some incendiary
going up oh this guy's grenades right on
me
i'm gonna try to flank him i'll distract
the sop
secondary power relay
uh can i shoot him through this window i
totally can't
hey
uh so sorry bob the other change um is
dark zone stuff which we'll discuss in a
little bit we'll do that after this
mission but this is the bigger one of
the bigger things in the uh new open
beta
oh [ __ ]
this job's
whatever assistance you need we can
handle it
good
because i need some relay boxes swapped
out
hey those relay
boxes so we're gonna have to carry some
one of us is gonna have to carry power
but you can drop it to shoot like look
at all these caskets i think these are
caskets right or these mid weapon crates
what do you think
they got flags on them right well they
don't look like caskets
i mean maybe they're like
geez okay so if i shoot it i shouldn't
feel better
maybe they're like
all the
cremated
urns
now you're just making stuff up out of
your butt man that was out of my ass
all right so where are we going oh shoot
there's totally a guy over there oh so
these guys are kind of new too so you're
gonna notice these guys with um they
have shields but they also have like
hatchets
so be careful of those guys oh so
they're uh they're gonna come right up
in my face yup because i just shot him
and i missed like a amateur i think i
got my shotgun he's on his way to let's
do it
party
okay let me see oh no
oh there's one behind us you got your
shotgun still yep take that guy out okay
i'll do a barrel roll
oh well that guy died sorry stream i did
a barrel roll instead of showing team
toaster thinks those are definitely
caskets
they're they're like ammo boxes
some of them look like crates and some
of them like you don't put flags on
crates though maybe it's like a
juxtaposition of like
how the world is handling the situation
they're like they're just like tossing
bodies in a pit yet they are uh all
about you know putting flags on ammo
crates and stuff because they're
you know
yeah
sure
so that's a new kind of mechanic in the
game i had to pick up a power thing to
then place it into that to get power
that's going to be like another one of
those that like kind of kind of carry it
farther and you can only have a pistol
when you're carrying it but you can't
just drop into cover and it'll just drop
on the floor so you can always pick it
up oh watch out there's a bunch of dudes
especially they're getting real close or
i'll get this um
the shield back oh [ __ ]
behind you
guys oh you're right there are two
i got you i got you i can heal up
yeah there's a couple of variations
right there's like um like a double like
a old school
just like
two barrel right like a semi-auto
is there another one uh there might be
one other one um sorry guys if if you
guys have questions just try to put a
question in front of it i'm trying to
play and watch i'm not doing the best
job i heard you but um try to answer
your question i think you're doing a
fine job oh thanks uh
is this the room that has a bunch of
people
oh yeah this is totally the room with a
[ __ ] ton of people can we crack one of
these things open where are you
okay okay so they're down there so you
know what it's a mixture of both yeah
right it's like i didn't see like ammo
crates and then caskets too so i totally
shot a casket like an [ __ ] because
you made me think that it wasn't anyways
sorry i'm gonna start killing these
dudes hey case closed
oh you're gonna blow up maybe you're
gonna kill your friend too oh don't run
away from your friend
oh he's running too
dude there's some purple guys so be
careful the ones with like armor or
shield or whatever more like they have
like armor bar
i haven't been following like the story
element of this mission
um we're trying to turn power back on i
believe
and one of the guys that's helping the
jtf or like that's part of your that
that you save as part of the
headquarters kind of like how you save
uh the one medic from madison square
right um he is trying to get the power
back on and you're helping him do that
and he's kind of stuck here because of
the cleaners faction more or less i
believe
um but truth be told i'm not much of a
story guy i'm here for the loot
what's in this crate why can't i open
this crate i'm here to loot and shoot
baby
dude i just realized i know how you like
that shooter mcgavin yeah luda
luda
that's like we should make a gift
let's do it and you can use that all the
time
um i'd be careful because i remember
there's a point where there's a bunch of
dudes
yeah
don't worry i'll throw down a sentry
right here yeah do it
get a little sentry turret distracted
oh i threw an aid at it
or wait
he's like the red
the red line is uh the thing's shooting
here oh watch out there's a guy on top
the century's suppressing them yeah
suppress the [ __ ] out of those guys
yeah yeah do that while the turn
suppressing them did you get them
i don't know did i oh the turrets had to
add a juice
it's kind of hard this keeps ricocheting
don't worry snipe them in the head
what you want this gun yeah i know
i know i want it bad yeah we can
probably get you one in the dz it's not
not a difficult task i don't think this
is joyousness eric but the story no i
know
uh do you want me to hold this
shut down yeah what is this uh here oh
yeah okay uh
it's on the floor ah
although i i'm pretty sure you want to
just leave it there
like kill these guys
well you can help out with your pistol
maybe you have a really good pistol oh
you can do it you can carry sidearm yeah
yeah you get your sidearm maybe you're
like dirty harry and you're just like
got your magnum charles bronson other
magnums oh okay
i am on fire
that's an interesting thing i couldn't
do anything while i was on fire
like i was trying to pat my fire out
oh hey it's kind of realistic you know
he shoots he scores is that body still
there it is
oh did he fly yeah the physics pretty
good
i can't run with this thing because it's
really good yeah yeah
that's why it's almost like you wanna
ditch it right now watch out for these
shield guys
what is this one just easy oh
don't worry a quick switch to my
is this on easy it's on level six and
we're zero six
and we can do the harder version later
hopefully i don't level
to eight that remember what happened
last time when i leveled the eight and
we couldn't get into the dark zone
together yeah that wasn't fun yeah no it
wasn't
you got you carrying that dead weight
right there yep
no problem don't worry uh i'll i'm
coming
i'll do some j's some jj's
hey we're both getting a workout now yep
don't worry maybe i'll get him like
where do i put this right here yeah okay
hold that x
don't give it to me
he
uh this one's normal i think normal for
this mission's level six uh hard would
probably be seven or eight
[ __ ] crypto you use the pistol a lot
i never used it because you have to
double tap
that's a double d you hold it you can
hold it too okay uh
yeah jk yeah double tap right i think i
think we thought that it was uh this one
okay
so this room is going to get filled
later i know there's going to be a boss
who's that dude in there oh that's the
guy that's helping us oh he's trying to
turn that power on
okay
he was oh he was stuck down here is that
he said
or he was already already down here this
buddy of ours
oh that guy's gonna be in there he's
safe
yeah he's down there trying to like fix
the power but it turns out
he needs some help
so
makes sense
i thought he was going to maybe turn on
us
but
he's a good guy anyway
get real lucky
it's faster to switch to the pistol than
reloading i just switched to my other
primary
point yeah exactly i mean like
switch my secondary and then i thought
you took care of these guys
i thought i took care of them too bro
uh oh no respawn
what happens if
we die then does the whole mission reset
or just i think it's part of it
oh what are you doing up there buddy
oh i remember this this is the zone that
you had
uh yeah there's that the
big guy's gonna show up eventually
across the way up top
remember when you had this gun in the
other beta oh my god
somebody did ask if the open bay is
going to go forward progress to final
game i don't think they're going to
also because you start to let the beta
at level four so we're skipping the
intro because they clearly want you to
watch that your level one to four
morning right
now
it doesn't really really
really happen right theta progression
yeah it's very rare i've only seen it in
a couple games
there was an mmo called lineage
and i was able to that opened it did
actually
which was interesting
but i haven't really experienced too
much at since then
i guess for an mmo it'd make things more
interesting too right
as far as actually if i put this down
now
get down there turret uh oh suppressing
fire
dude the big guy doesn't care about the
noise
oh he's not dead though dude
i set it up already it did not uh
oh book it i'm booking it oh he's not
happy i mean
cover i'm all right right i
maybe
yeah
don't worry i'll just keep sniping him
in the head
oh i got i got the main canister thing
nope he's he's almost done tacos give
him the business
yeah
suck it oh there's still a guy [ __ ]
oh we're dead
that's the mission
cool
it's quick got some greens did you get
any blues man
got some real
average
that's
uh oh downstairs
is there just nothing else up here like
i don't know while you do that i'll just
uh you know
i'm coming
i'm coming
that's kind of how i feel right now
maybe we can go lockpick yeah
i surrender man hey i'm cool i'm cool
i'm cool
yeah the turret is definitely more of
like a restriction distraction rather um
she'll probably go get your turret huh
after this i should go turn that mission
in for you
oh cool good idea
um
oh yeah
i'm always looking for that you know
maybe we can get
invisible rob again
oh my god
people love that
people like really liked it
did they oh she needs help does she yeah
are you going to give her something yeah
i guess what'd you get you get something
oh what'd you
we're gonna go back and then after we
get to the uh hq we're gonna go into the
dark zone
dark zone it up
it looks so much hotter
all right
that's a good time for questions if you
have questions
has the ps4 beta started no i believe
it's like 12 or 1 am tonight uh it was
1am for xbox so i would just pacific 1am
pacific where xbox one last night or
this morning so i'd assume it's uh 1am
it's probably a 24-hour thing
yeah what was last time like few days
right
um they extended it uh extra day i
believe last time but the gap between
like xbox oh it was a day yeah oh it was
one day i think it was 24 hours yeah oh
never mind yeah i was like same thing
was like a thursday and then a friday
huh hate how slow this is hmm
look it over
okay so i go over here to the tech wing
oh they got some blues i ain't got
enough money
shot out give me that classic ak
are you selling oh what is this
burst fire mp5 i didn't know i had that
maybe you should try that out
that sounds hot
all right and now i do
send us over here
oh yeah i'm just selling stuff while
you're doing that sell away
got a lot of level 8 stuff i can't use
which is awesome
hey you want something else you let me
know maybe the the mods vendor's got
something
he's got some scopes that i could afford
cool
rate of fire and magazine size
um
come back when you feel like buying
if i wasn't so broke i would buy
yeah
um
oh yeah we should restock
always be restocking
that's a pro tip i like that
have the graphics been
upscaled since the closed beta i don't
think so i think the graphics look about
the same what do you think
yeah they definitely haven't noticed any
difference in graphics
uh tell me when you turn that puppy in
notification i think you gotta go
upstairs oh
can you afford it though no i got an ak
somehow yeah
well it's less dps because it doesn't
have all your mods so don't forget oh
that's right i was thinking about that
the other day i was like oh okay
good
point
man why are their guns so expensive and
mine aren't worth [ __ ]
this is a double barrel shotgun 75
division bucks
did his bucks
so there are stats guys um
i think the first one is like dps or
firearms the second one stamina and the
third one's electronics
um later on if uh we're not going to get
any high-end weapons here but
certain weapons
maybe armor have perks on them and you
have to have specific
stats otherwise they won't work
okay and maybe if i run you can just
fast travel to me right
oh i'm done i'm going outside now oh
okay ready to go ah well then you're
already ahead of me here we're gonna run
to the dark zone
and we're gonna hopefully get some new
webs
some neat armor
yeah i want that m1
so should i equip the turret i mean if
you're rocking it i could do something
else well why don't you it's up to you i
have the upgraded
pulse uh oh keep that yeah okay i'm
gonna get rid of the turret then
i mean do you what do you think about
the turn i think it's a distraction oh
no
let's try it out i'll use it and we'll
try it out uh
i should definitely keep health uh we'll
try it out
during an extraction and see what it
does
okay
um unless you've already done that i've
done before i haven't done it in the
extraction point i've used it to kind of
distract ai while i had while soloing
the dark zone still isn't the funnest
place when you're by yourself right it's
actually pretty rough
nearby because in this game
oh we could listen to that echo but
whatever
um
in this game one level is like
apparently a huge deal
and they will just hurt you real bad
hey man why you guys leveled up to seven
steal that guy's stuff oh did you
i feel like i leveled faster
this time oh yeah i think so too
i mean i'm not sure why five was quit
well you got to fight pretty quick but
yeah
it took a while to get to eight and it
looks like
yeah but it was like a difference of one
mission right so it's like
right not really sure why that would
have did it right
well i mean like i think
i leveled up because i was in your group
in a group with you and you just killed
a guy i wasn't doing anything but
walking sick so i wonder if that's the
case too
team toaster's biggest concern is a
lack of content like destiny
uh hard to say there's gonna be four
dlcs right um not it'll be interesting
to see
we've been theory crafting and
hypothesizing a lot like what's the end
game is it the dark zone is there
something else like who knows
how do you get skins for weapons so you
need to get uh mods or uh spray cans and
i believe one of the ways you can do
that oops
is you can get them off citizens when
you give them like
like water yeah they tend to kind of
give you more of like anything like that
yeah but
they tend to give you more like
appearance-based stuff i think aaron
said he got one off of like one of the
people he helped they gave him like a
green screen spare ass brickhead
uh and i'm sure there'll be other places
to get them like back like loot bags and
stuff like that
and uh you'll know if there's a citizen
that requires aid because they'll kind
of like be scannable or something
they'll get scammed yeah you walk by
them they tend to like kind of limp like
they're in need as well yeah hack a
computer get some experience
you're learning um
uh there is one thing i noticed though
in the dark zone those all the bags
finally have stuff in them you know how
we were looting those small bags and
they didn't really have stuff in them oh
okay like now they finally have like a
flashbang or incendiary bullet or
something right so it's not like
uh
you get nothing
the dark zones walled off so one of the
issues i feel like where the infection
hit hardest to the point where no one is
not a lack of ai so you think there's a
little more well so one of the changes
was it was supposed to add more ai as
well as the air is supposed to have a
little bit more hp i believe yeah um
yesterday night when i ran around i
didn't see
like ai
as or like i didn't see
more ai rather right sure i saw them in
all those points of interest and stuff
like that
but i thought i was expecting to kind of
see them just littered around as you run
but um that didn't happen so we'll see
if that was just last night or not
i hear a lot of gunfire must be a turd
all right you ready let's do it
oh look at you
oh there you are
i love it can you see me can we do
invisible
um
let's go
to the sporting store because i know
that uh there's a chest there oh yes
actually you want to go down the subway
so i've been down the subway that's good
and uh
it was like it was literally the same uh
uh boss that we just had it was like a
big i was a big flamer dude
we got a dps this guy we won't get
experience there you go
um
so i want to say those guys were there
before because they're in this like park
area but yeah
totally in the park oh yeah these guys
so for those of you that don't
understand there's a purple exp bar
that's above my normal exp bar and that
is my dark zone level
um so rob these crates
are supposed to they're supposed to be
more of them now oh that's some uh did
you get something from that yeah yeah oh
you got some type of
light machine gun that's correct um
but yeah they're supposed to be more
stuff to pick up uh and
compared to before some of them require
you to be a certain dark zone level to
open them
and some of them require you to have
dark zone keys now the dark zone key
chests were like on really long cooldown
timers before
someone's exploring do you want to go
back
to uh the subway or no oh yeah yeah
sorry sorry yeah you're right let's go
to subway um
but yeah the dark zone uh chest that
require keys
they're on a shorter cool down time
right now so you should be able to open
them fast like sooner than you were yeah
and close beta but you do need a dark
zone key which you would get from um
drops off uh ais
are those things like master keys
because i have i never was able to do
that every time um yeah you just have to
get a specific key off it's called the
dark zone oh [ __ ] sorry sorry sorry oh
whoa whoa whoa buddy whoa whoa sorry
whoa i gotta no he shot me too well i
shot him first well he's a real piece of
[ __ ] yeah he could probably hide her
timer in the subway that's why he's
running
that's why he's running
all right
well i bet this place is probably clean
right if he went through it maybe
it depends
i don't know if he could have did that
solo he might have been able to uh
usually the way is it down here
i feel like he's down here
it should be down here
see any bad guys
i see a uh non-hostile agent oh you want
to smoke them let's wait
dude where the hell did you just go did
you just teleport
or the guy dude where did he go dude
oh you're right there yeah like he like
logged out or something
should have shot him maybe he knows
about that
maybe
maybe he saw us before
okay here's something in here
what
what's that required rank eight uh i'm
six unfortunately
i haven't seen that before
yeah so there's more of those these are
these bigger crates you just need to be
higher level this one doesn't need a
dark zone key though so i'm just gonna
get higher rank so by getting to get
higher rank in the dark zone you just
need to kill enemy ai
uh or kill rogue agents i think these
are all dead bodies actually yep that's
a dead body
did that bleed
i see red coming out
look at my ice cream
yeah that looks like blood
well then
uh so you want to get out of here oh
what was that that was me shooting the
body to see blood
uh are we gonna get out of here yeah
this is pretty boring let's get out of
here
so that was unfortunate that's like one
of the things that happened in closed
beta as well if somebody cleared out an
area that there were it took too long ai
does they don't respawn that quickly
india in areas right like on the streets
they spawn pretty this is exiting the
contaminated area
all right we're gonna go to the sports
store because that's where my marker is
at spirits
let's do it
that guy's dead
tends to be case around here
a lot of dead people
dying sucks
yeah
oh what was that
oh there's a dude non-hostile and
there's a guy with a gun floating gun
what or he's that he has the floating
gun maybe i don't know oh it's a glitch
oh i thought you were saying yeah what
are you shooting at
i don't know what are you oh there's a
baddies okay level fives just take them
scrapper
i really shouldn't be doing what i'm
doing i am the scrapper oscar
something like that
i thought there's a sniper
sniper all right i'm gonna try out this
turret
do it go baby
there's another guy up top
oh whoa this is a rogue team dude oh
yeah oh yeah smoke them
can we smoke them yep
warm xg and machine you're going down
sir oh is he down no
but
i'm falling back a little bit because
there's four of them i do try to try to
try to keep
oh one guy was so close to dying
hella [ __ ] loot
they got a 90 second timer dude we can
do it
dude how did he live through that
i'm gonna pulse get our crits up
dude jimmer's so low jimmy is asking for
it
that's my turn
that guy's crazy oh my god that guy's
crazy for even doing what he just did
you're turning flank yep you see him oh
he's getting up on that thing
oh he's crazy
he's dead can you finish him with melee
yeah i'm i can shoot him
don't want him
got him
sweet we got some dark zone expedients
where do you think they're going i just
leveled up
oh he's so close where
yeah
john cena sucks
hey hey watch out shout out yeah oh i
just got down can you uh can you oh no
no no can you uh res me before he kills
me i'm trying okay
[ __ ]
uh [ __ ] dude i'm sorry i kind of [ __ ]
that up you killed him though yeah i
will in a sec all right well when do you
want him
i believe in you give him that shotgun
give him that yeah give him that give
him the business yeah yeah
yeah mail him yeah you guys couldn't see
it
but rob got the mc vengeance dude we
just took on that whole we took on four
dudes i don't know what they're doing
success i'm in the safe house i'll meet
you i'll meet you in a second come get
that loot come get that hot loot oh yeah
that was my fault i shouldn't have gone
out like no i laid the other guy
that was like worth it though i did sing
too soon i sang that john cena sucks too
soon i thought he couldn't see me but
but it was really nice i tried to do
that you can't see me but he clearly saw
me
are you coming to me yeah i'm coming to
you i'm going to try to pick up whatever
loot you left
behind but we got a lot of experience
from that a lot of dark zone dollars so
it's always worth it um
especially i don't like you never really
want to go rogue when you have loot
um
so yeah that's a oops i'm at the sports
store already whoops where the hell are
you at
uh my death location i don't know i'm
actually doing something really dumb
like on the other dude i feel like
they're going to go back to get their
loot though yeah good idea you know what
that's actually really true isn't it
yeah they're totally going to go get
their leaves i'm in a
gtfo i'm coming to you though is there
any loot left though yeah i like that
okay yeah i got to pick some loot up
there are two guys here though
uh do you remember the names one was
general machine jimmer
and i didn't check vicious something
does uh what's that guy's name yep
that's machine
oh yeah but uh he's a little late
because i got his [ __ ]
i'm gonna go pick up the stuff we got i
guess we got from the the drops from the
normal dudes
hey buddy viper
were you that [ __ ] yeah you best that
you best to put your hands up that was
so great yeah it would have been great
if i didn't die oh did he put his hands
up yeah he did the surrender motion
um you want to go to the sports store
uh i mean i got a full oh yeah you want
to all right let's go do a distraction
let's go far down so these dicks don't
show up dude they're all here yeah they
are
i dare you
go rogue i'll put a little rouge on you
do it
that was great
rock those fools hmm
take all the stuff rob rob took i think
rob's full
you can only carry up to six things i
was gonna go through and like sort and
deconstruct
i mean if they i mean if they're showing
up i don't yeah that's like the next
level thing is when you want to start
kind of consolidating your good loot and
not just picking up everything right i
mean
typically it's just like you want to do
that for like blues and greens right
like correct
15. some [ __ ] could be going down here
oh
oh oh there's a lot of guys here i don't
like it oh oh jimmer just got killed
by
somebody
uh they're extracting back here if you
want to try to extract i think they're
just extracting as well
yeah they're extracting let's try to get
it before they can turn on this
i wish we didn't have anything we could
have totally turned on them
oh i couldn't put mine on there
i couldn't put mine on there did you get
yours on there oh yeah
okay i'm getting mine on there oh let's
kill this guy this guy this guy still
has his bag dude that's how you know he
has lube
your buddies over there are your buddies
over there or what
are you are you uh scrapped oh
uh oh uh oh they this they sent
something they sensed it
oh no they probably came back because
his buddy was like dude i didn't get the
extract
he's like guys hey there's two guys here
and they're like following me dude
i told you right the best thing is in
this game there's that proximity chat
oh right i swear to god even last night
even last night it's like hey hey
there's a guy here should we kill him
he's got luke he's got luke yeah the
whole time i'm thinking i'm like dude i
hear you guys
[ __ ] here i just run i'm just like
running and there's like four guys just
behind me like oh god just don't don't
don't fire on me please
um oh yeah let's go to a checkpoint like
an area so so far we haven't seen any
just like
mobs like in the streets like we thought
maybe we would see we thought we'd see
more kind of like just kind of
sporadically spread out on these streets
but this is kind of what the closed beta
was like it was uh you know a lot of
empty streets
except for like key locations and then
sometimes there's some areas outside of
the extraction points where they're um
there's more mobs we've got to be
careful in here i've died in here a
couple oh i remember i remember the like
well that probably the only time i ever
saw enemies in here was with uh you and
aaron oh man they're not in here this is
a good spot
yeah see i wonder like
i don't know yeah this is like these
areas should be the areas that like
you'd expect
here's more frequent a frequency i'll
have a dark zone maybe you'll get loot
from here we'll see
feel like you did you expect oh it's
garbage but i'll take it a mil or terry
and i got 300 dz funds did you get some
hot dz funds
uh no
that sucks
um but at least you got loot right
yeah i did
sorry i totally uh cut you off what were
you all good uh i was saying yeah you'd
expect like uh
ai to like respond here pretty like
quickly like at least in the areas right
like on the street i don't care too much
about uh we can go near the library i
know the library has some guys like
right outside of it and i can also go
into the safe room and show people the
new high-end weapons
oh there's there's dudes over here
behind that fence area
oh opening up the shot
oh no you ran into the shot what
what oh that guy's one shot okay
oh man i'm at level five now tc right
now easy
yeah there's a couple dudes over here
all right well i'm gonna enjoy this
grenade
and shoot him through the through the
car it's not having it though
oh there's a lot of grenades going on
here oh
they're getting pinched from both sides
i'm getting grenaded though
you don't have a silencer on that
or or the effects of war am i going deaf
because of fire yeah a lot of grenades
in your ear so there should be some bags
here if you want to open one of them
there's one like there and there's like
one over here
there's one here i'll open this one
there's one next to you got double
barrel shocking
oh and you gave me hunting pads oh
that's hot there's a
oh you opened it i guess
what else
no there was another little bag but i
guess there's nothing in that one
ah sup game spot what about this game 10
out of 10 maybe question mark i don't
know it's a beta i can't judge anything
based off of the beta i'm gonna go into
the safe room before we go to the
library library
libre oh whoa
wait where's safer is that close jesus
yeah is there another one no no no
there's multiple entrances so these are
the two new
uh high-end weapons if you didn't play
the uh the original closed beta there
was an assault rifle and a shotgun in
the first uh in the closed beta in this
open beta there's this uh liberator
high-end assault rifle oops and a light
machine gun now here are those perks i
was talking about uh the first one's
competent
uh
see you need certain like
stamina firearms electronics to hit some
of those
directives but yeah the pricing on the
high-end weapons have doubled yeah right
it was like 3 000 3 000 last time yeah a
little over 3 000 ish last time uh now
they're like 7 000 damn um i'm not
really sure if it's because they think
that you're gonna get more
out of those crates now like because
you'll get them more frequently so you
get money more frequently and maybe
because they thought maybe they upped
the ai uh you get you know more money
off them right but i have what fifteen
hundred dark zone dollars we've killed
some guys i played maybe
level seven that's hour-ish
so
i got a ways to go before i could buy a
high-end weapon wow uh did you use talk
i did dude that's like
like you'll get like i mean with the
last closed beta like i mean i got that
shotgun
and then the beta stopped right like
it's going to be the same case here like
you're going to get it and then maybe
oh there's there's totally dudes uh i i
got the assault rifle and i probably
could have got the shotgun too if i
wanted to farm it but then oh i missed
oh i missed
that's terrible
watch out there's a lot of dudes over
there just fyi and there's at least one
boss
and a couple grenades oh i see him
they're coming oh grenade
oh man
oh this is probably terrible
as i put
health
yeah that's kind of like the big thing
about it right it's it's not really
doing any dps or anything
i got him
ain't nobody going to touch hot rod
thresher is hiding up though
all right this guy's playing scared
dude this guy's not taking damage
really you see that i just three
thousand crit i'm like four times in the
head watch watch it i can't again i
can't even see him oh wait no he's
thinking he's it's his armor it's kind
of hard to see a lot of armor though
well they shouldn't have it white two
different color
i feel like it's hard
uh see the crazy thing is like once you
get rid of the armor they die a lot
faster oh yeah it's pretty quick for
sure
if i could freaking hit him in the head
hiding behind this oh uh latency
all right got him
yeah he didn't draw blues though dude
what's up with that have you seen a
single blue uh i have
seen it in a blue
oh there's
that's funny uh because there is a blue
oh really yeah was it a cosmetic like
teal blue or no it's it's the blue that
you want oh nice i don't i didn't get a
blue
i feel like i got you
that's funny yeah you killed him
all right
uh it looks like we're getting loaded
again here so there are purples right uh
yes there are purples at level eight
i've never seen it at level seven uh
once you get to the darks there's a
different dark zone bracket like if you
guys see in the top it says like dark
zone player bracket one to seven there's
a dark zone player bracket eight of
eight at least in the betas
and um those
oh i can open this dark zone chest too
oh tight let's see it i got [ __ ]
i got money though see i'm full
this is when you want to kind of look at
your
dark zone inventory
and say well what don't i need do i want
something good
get rid of this guy
get rid of this guy
and hope that those two things um are
better also there's crafting in this
game guys uh it's not in the beta though
so it can't show you unfortunately but
there's also crafting
oh really you can craft
like a like a part to a gun what do you
what do you mean
uh yeah there's a crafting table i don't
know what you can make i'm assuming i
can make weapons and armor but it's not
available so i was not able to check
um so what would that be able to do what
would that mean like you pick up like
random reasons yeah there's parts
there's parts weapons
and stuff like that and
already
yeah there's like a store i remember
seeing where it's like you go in there
and you can yeah you get like crafting
parts there's like talents and perks
that we can't access either look at that
[ __ ]
it's all like
blurred out
like what are you gonna do right you
know all right well experience
uh
i
am tracto ready to extract out do you
want to go to the same spot or a
different spot go to a different spot
show them another spot and probably this
one's a little less safe that we like
going to that upstairs one because
there's a lot of spots we can post up at
right oh there's supposed to be a
package oh there you go oh i know which
one we're going to actually there's a
spot i like oh yeah i will show you oh
show me
oh i just saw a non-hostile agent
oh there's already one being called in
there so let's see how this goes this
should be fun you think they're gonna
keep your pc are they gonna go row
you know it's really hard to tell the
the human mind is a very interesting
thing well one of the ways to tell too
is do they have a satchel on their back
right if they don't have one they might
go rogue
all right we got time too 30 seconds i
don't know someone corrected me someone
said that it's brown i said yellow
what's brown the bag on your back
cause that's like it signifies
yellow it's radioactive yeah you always
see dudes in yellow when it comes down
to radioactive exactly yellow brown
but yeah it signifies that if you guys
see people like the satchels on their
back that means they have loot and
you might want to kill them for it
where's your spot at it is
i mean i like it
it's right where the guy is oh yeah oh
there's two of them okay so like that
area right there another fun fact they
got satchels another fun thing to have
is your pulse ability
and that'll tell you how many muscles
and non-hostiles are around right right
now it appears that they're gonna get
rid of their [ __ ] so i'm gonna get rid
of my [ __ ] too
so there's no point going rogue on those
guys
because they don't have that loot
um
also we got to be careful we extract too
much uh our
thing's gonna get full so we gotta be
mindful of that it was a decent amount
though right i don't know oh man what is
it it's i wanna say it's like like a 36
item
yeah something i think oh what's this
guy want
does he have luke i don't know he's just
giving me a mug
yeah you best to back off original 20. i
see you got loot bro i see oh he's got
loot
you want to smoke him let's smoke his
hand all right let's let him call it in
oh for
sure him call it dude he knows what's up
i love it
where'd he go
i'm looking at him
oh there's two jimmer's here oh an x
machine and x machine all right all
right hey this gamer doesn't have loot
though this is why i say we do okay okay
follow me out and pretend we're leaving
all right and then we're gonna loop
around here on the left i like it i like
your i like your tactics
real next level here real meta
all right all right if things go south
we're trying we're going to try to book
it to the library okay
oh you know what i didn't check i didn't
check if those like weird um red zones
existed right exist still or not but
all right all right no no don't don't
let that switch start okay
okay
real quick
real quiet like
okay when do we go what i don't know
like close to extraction right because
they're going to run up oh easy easy
easy
they're going to run up to the
helicopter and try to like get rid of it
you know what i mean right so that's
when we want to we want to pounce on
them that's what we want to balance baby
i'm loving it
all right
are they no no the rope's not there yet
man the rope's not there fair enough
well like i think you should drop your
turret down too oh i will drop that down
no doubt
no dignity all right should we do it
now no no we wanna we want them all to
cluster let them see you oh okay they
don't see me
okay they saw me all right let's do it
should we go all right
yep oh yeah do it now do it now i'm
lobbing a grenade
did they get their stuff out though no
they didn't
i got a [ __ ] i got one of a [ __ ]
and i'm gonna tell you i'm just gonna
immediately
watch out for the camera
[ __ ]
all right all right hey hey get to the
library did you did it let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go
dude i extracted i think he had a good
rifle did he yeah
oh no no no hey there's a there's a guy
here there's a guy here
light him up let his ass up you know it
dude that's what i'm done
all right where's the library at i'm
going straight ahead
oh
yeah we got ranked four we're gonna
go on a manhunt soon oh
man thanks to our right is it to our
right love it do we do we screw up i
feel like we screwed up no no no no this
is right it's just straight
is it
uh
which one of us pulls out the map
it's right here isn't it i don't know
you tell me all right cover me all right
do it dude
oh there's dudes behind us they're also
road rails
they're also ropes just get out of here
right we were right where straight yes
go go go i'll bodyblock you i'll
bodyblock you
[ __ ] okay so
uh where's the rope to the right
yeah yeah okay
i believe in you babe
we gotta hop this
yeah yeah we gotta hop it and then we
gotta go up the up the rope
oh that's good because
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go
go go go go go go go go go go go
all right so which side do you want to
watch you want to watch your side
okay so like there's one that we the one
behind you're gonna have to do two i'm
gonna have to do two because there's two
that are really close there's one that's
far away that like
i have to like watch yeah yeah but they
can't go wrap around you're right you're
right okay all right i'm not familiar
with it yeah we good we can all right
where's the uh there's got 160 seconds
of heat
of heat to kind of you know oh man that
is [ __ ]
it's
sick
crap
of course it's trap i dare you to come
up here
like asking to die
you should heal yourself you're
absolutely right
it's also hard to lob grenades up here
like really hard right you were telling
me that this spot is like filthy and
then in the in the closed beta you were
able to kind of like use that red zone
to get out i don't know if that still
exists but if the [ __ ] hits the fan you
know that wire you're at i think we go
down there and then we drop down the one
i'm at yeah
not like the one that's like the into
the red
wait is that the other side one yeah so
that's the other okay
yeah that's the one we need to to drop
down to it's really bad
to loop around right to give them the
old
loop around i don't think they're going
to come though because you know why
we're i didn't get anything josh we
whatever i got something we got but see
the thing is we will get something if we
just survive this we'll get experience
and dark zone dollars type
yeah
and then a hot reputation on the server
do you know what the uh
well like each so i'm well we're level
four rogue yeah we're we're level four
rogue right now do you have to know like
what each level uh not as far as like
cash or not sure but obviously manhunt
which makes it so you're on the map
for everybody like in the top left
there's a manhunt out for that person
and you get the most for that for sure
um
is it kills what what constitutes as a
level it's kills i believe like we
killed like four dudes there or three
damn yeah
no we killed is it three or four i think
it was three at least three at least
they were it's too quiet it says nacho
2795 i know right like
i don't sense any heat i don't think
i don't think they're coming dude you'd
be crazy to try to come up here i also
think they don't give a [ __ ] and maybe i
think i mean it's open beta there could
be some amateurs you know fair enough i
was about to say like
it's kind of widely known right
um i mean i think it's widely known for
anyone that plays closed beta the
library is one of like one of the better
spots to hide the subway is also another
spot i saw people hiding at a lot why
what's in this i've seen people running
it's just that like it's like kind of
disorienting because there's like you
know what i mean if you've never been
down there yeah there's like you could
kind of get a little lost it's kind of
like a little bit of a maze yeah i don't
know also because i think people like to
fight down very narrow corridors where
you can't get flanked from right
remember that one alley that yeah that
one alley yeah but they had an out
though because they had like a red area
see we got 317 bucks
you got 317. yeah what did you get 241
two folding one all right all right cool
no problem no problem we're good
oh man that was funny
dude the best go get them again oh man
the best was that uh when those two
other guys were down and we were just
oh you want to get this pve guys
what's up
oh yeah
yeah let's click clear it out of course
always be killing the ai oh oh what the
hell was that oh there's a guy on you
whoa i don't know how that happened
what
those guys aren't flying doors no the
grenade guys if you hit them in the
right spots they uh they they explode
like that too oh yeah it's all those
dudes again
i got dropkick to deal with
[ __ ] there's a lot of dudes
oh eric huh
julio that is extremely nice of you the
beers have arrived my beers have arrived
sweet drunk shooting
oh god i'm going to die from drunk
shooting
you're not even drunk yet i know don't
let the stream know that though
they can't see me this isn't going too
well now we're good we're good we're
good we just gotta
i'm not doing too well
take your time you could always hide out
the safe house
you know
this is not good oh is that grenade i
can't tell because i'm all right it's
it's definitely probably grenade
oh no i'm out of like good ammo like my
good rifle ammo
and we can't actually we can't run to
the safe house because we're in combat
we'd have to run kind of like out of
yeah no problem what the heck oh i'm
gonna give him a little
i don't know is that a smoke or a flash
this guy is trying to shoot like a
gangster i could shoot like a gangster
too
because this worked out for everyone
that ever shot like that
okay i got one i got one
you can't really hold it down like i'm
doing a terrible job because i'm just
like spraying praying but you really
need to feather it
i can always revive you just uh just
chill we're getting there i just killed
two guys
i'm gonna light this guy up
like uh
yeah we're gonna go when i throw that
grenade buddy
oh yeah oh yeah
all right just pulsed it we got more
damage now
god i'm running out of ammo
you got that hot sentry still oh i keep
forgetting little mini me
i want some of this
yeah give him the business little gun
do work son
drop kick murphy have a little
incendiary granada
oh i hope you're on fire jerks all right
we're gonna try to move positions here
we're in the foot
wow you just called me an mf er
you know what line i keep hearing all
the time from them is oh they got alex
oh really yeah it's like this it damn
everyone's alex in this game oh aldi
like um random ai right right oh nice
you got the the big boss oh there's a
blue
oh you got a blue yeah off your kill
now i'm just gonna
ride up and do this guy dirty
i need ammo you want to go to the safe
house
and then extract thee
i got no ammo man oh yeah sure stock up
yeah
get some medic get some frags the safe
house is like right here and you have a
little breather
there's is there anything over there hey
running out of ammo got 300 rounds no
dude i was out of my marksman rifle
that's the thing that does the big
damage
let's go
i'm a lightweight yeah cheers man we got
what bruce what i want to get the safe
house first oh well i'm in the safe
house yeah i know
where is the
damn
truck right there it's uh pass that rope
into the
[ __ ] i'm right
well let's just say it sounds more like
something uh progress doesn't carry over
can i play bait on pc probably at one am
ish today or today and tomorrow
no it's not i'd know
josh but you know
all right we're gonna extract and
hopefully get some extract ease like
last time go rogue on them i like that
and then hopefully steal their loot
that's the plan and i like that i'm
already fully stocked that's cool
let's get back to the street do you want
to go to the same spot or do you want to
go to another spot
the beta should be out tomorrow for ps4
hey game spot who is alex alex is one of
those thugs that we killed that doesn't
have a name oh i was yeah i was just
saying it's like a it's like a generic
script that i keep hearing from ai
they're just like oh damn they shot alex
well they got alex which one did you
want to go to here all the time um i go
back to the old one or that upstairs one
i mean i guess the library is the is the
clutch way right yeah so that's closer
all right let's go back to where we just
came from then um all right
how much loot do i have i got like four
oh i'm full all right
really hope they don't remember our
names from the last time we killed them
good
point
which means we got to be extra frosty
like that car
i actually have a blue so i'm going to
be pissed if i die this time i do too oh
do you it's just a grip but but hey man
it'd be blue there's a grip
blues be blues right now
that's true good point i yeah so i don't
know
do you feel like there's been more ai at
the like no points of interest though no
you think it's the same amount like what
we know do you feel like that was more
that felt like a little bit okay good
point yeah the last one that we we were
up there
there uh there's ai at the gas station
oh someone's someone's extracting
there's ai at the gas station oh
well i don't give a [ __ ] about them
really all right let's go
all right fine fine but i'm just saying
we'll have to run past them later that's
oh well let's go whatever nah that's
fine
well you can't pick up loot so oh [ __ ]
oh no he's not looking at me he's level
five
what a loser
uh let's put the extraction near the
spot where you we we flank them from i
guess
that's another tip for you guys uh in
the dark zone you have this whole entire
yellow orangey field to shoot off your
flare it like pops up up and down like
or up up and off i guess
you could tell so it'll be close to this
spot it won't be directly but you don't
want to put it right in the middle where
everyone can shoot okay so this is my
spot right here i like this are you
gonna post up there all right i'll post
up i'll post up near the uh
oh wait [ __ ] is that your spot i always
thought i could yeah it's like right yes
all right i'll post up near the uh
the
i don't know dumpster thing charlotte
i'm gonna
yeah yeah right here find this little
nook so what i do with the ping is i'll
ping it like
now
really yeah and then like by the time it
gets to like 15 seconds you'll have it
recharged all right i'll ping right now
then and uh then you can get that last
minute
surveillance
oh
yeah no i think that's enemy right no no
that's a skull that's a rogue
well he's not here anymore i dare him to
come roll up on us or is he
damn i really want to use some of these
weapons oh you're right i have pulse up
again already
so that that's that's about right jtf
chopper is inbound
all right did they add anything to the
open bay yeah there's a new mission
opens up the tech wing so you can get
the little mini turret that rob has
uh there's no mods on it yet no they're
shooting at the oh oh who are those two
guys
i don't know if they saw me but they do
they have do they have bags they do okay
that guy doesn't
dude there's a bunch of dudes here
uh all right i'm gonna make a play for
it
i don't feel good about it throw down my
turret i don't oh someone just shot me
but it was the ai i'm getting my loot
out of here though you might want to as
well
oh [ __ ] no too many dudes oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it wouldn't let me i swear it's
okay it's okay it's okay we'll do it
again we'll do it again
oh this guy's still got loot viper viper
still got loot i want these other guys
to leave so i can merc viper and get
some so is there a limit
there must be or there's a time limit no
but like
there's a number of people can only put
the thing on at a time
that was that was mine that was my drone
spicy how's my drone oh hey viper who's
doing this oh they're on voice com
there's four dudes on voice com i don't
like it oh i can do extraction right
here where i'm standing do it
oh someone else did it okay okay okay
let me see how many we survey how many
people have loot there's a lot of heat
here though ping them
pinging them does nothing though right
now right you've got a bird
i'm pretty sure they're if they're not
hot they pop up as white
oh yeah you're right
but i can't tell they have bags he's got
a lot of guys man he's got a bag four
five six
that guy doesn't have a bag oh we got a
rogue over here oh yeah
oh he's running
everyone's chasing him
good let him go
okay who's gotta be gonna go get a bag
oh you got a bag laughing canuck
oh get him get him yeah yeah engage him
in combat before he
oh he's trying to get out
oh there will be no rolling sir
uh-oh
yeah give us those d's all right hey
where's that guy that had a bag a
laughing canuck
oh there's there's a guy over here
there's like four dudes over here
dare you to murk me
oh you're still over there
yeah i want to get rid of this [ __ ] oh
right you i forgot you totally forgot
your stuff
i'll have to protect you with my life oh
[ __ ] there's two more dudes here
oh i don't have ping yet i'm about to
have ping though
all right that guy has
loot there's a skull to our left
i'm gonna ping
all right lone wolf's stuck in the air
he's got loot
this guy is literally stuck he's
shooting the ground
he's mid air
he's chilling
oh some guy just killed someone did you
get your stuff out
good damn there's a lot of people here
dude would not be a good time to go
or is it there's a guy here he didn't
make it he didn't make it all right
let's wait let's wait
over here come on over here yeah okay
oh yeah we got to make it look we got to
play koi oh yeah the extraction's over
guys
nothing to see here
oh who's that guy who's that guy this is
the guy this is the guy oh that's the
guy
okay okay yeah but where is it what's
our exit strategy
dude you know the drill dude the library
is so far away from where we're going
right now
might have to go subway oh there's some
other friendlies
he's like hey guys wait up there's two
uh dudes following me oh that guy's
rogue he's oh five seconds he's coming
out it's five seconds you gotta tag him
before he oh
lucky oh stay on target okay stay on
target
stay on target
i see him do you dude he's got some
homies though huh his name's some stupid
like
actually his name was alex oh i can't oh
oh his name's alex yeah which makes it
even more they got alex he's more
appropriate
oh [ __ ] they got alex
the question is this i always have any
buddies [ __ ] where'd he go i think he
made a left is that alex no that's not
now let's just search something
i will ping
you can't run from the paper
[ __ ]
it's okay well let's let's let's damn it
what do you think do you think maybe
he's going to this top extraction
i see him what oh he's up all right is
he back on the hunt
is
oh he's leaving
well if he leaves he's not going to lose
his loot he's going to realize
oh maybe he's real dude he's probably
going to get him on the way bomb and
he's probably really dumb and he's just
like i don't know he only loses it if he
walks like three out totally right so
he'll into the door is okay into the
dark zone doors okay
but what he doesn't realize is he's
gonna be like oh i can't get my lead out
okay i gotta go extract it and then
we're gonna sit right here oh
i don't think he's gonna come back then
i don't think so
i also uh don't really know if that was
him or not oh
i just saw a guy do we know where that
the extraction is right now is it the
same spot we were at
let's go check
it let's go find out
oh
what i don't know
what'd you see
there's a non-hostile agent
do you have a bag
of jacket no but i don't think so a
little satchel on him
satch
oh man 15 seconds i don't think we're
gonna make it i think he probably got
his loot out
yeah uh well i kind of want to see
if there's another
landmark whatever we could go down and
uh shh what else is there there's the
gas station what haven't we done yet
koreatown which is behind us which is
like i have never seen ai on that street
really ever i have all right let's go
back
oh wait it's in front of me jesus
oh man you're far away
i was just running to the dz
my radar has got red in front of me
somewhere
yep there's a bad guy
here wait where
hey buddy
dude that was [ __ ] weird
what level you seven
that was super weird on me you like
warped to a different location
yeah
and then i am booked and then you were
you were standing on a car and then you
disappeared and now you're back where
you were not invisible no so
hey not a hostile agent do you have a
bag on you
damn it
do you want to go to the extraction
point maybe we can kill that guy
let's do it they're tracking bro
oh hi they're extracting let's go let's
we're close we're close we're going to
go get these guys we're going to kill
him and then we're going to get the loot
out
i like that idea
that's the hope
let's do it
all right you want me to ping now or
later
okay
there's one guy behind the canister see
him i think that's it do you think
that's a guy
should we should we tell me what his
name is give a little bit of time here
hold on i can't
i can't see it joe payboy
does he have do you see if he has a
backpack since you're on the other side
of him oh he's packing oh yeah okay okay
we gotta make sure nobody else shows up
and then we're gonna we're gonna get him
all right we're gonna get him should i
hide
no just well he didn't see you his whole
back is his back is turned to you no
but he can still see me
like his back
he can look i mean he can look to his
right i mean if i was him i'd be looking
[ __ ] everywhere
okay
should we do it now five seconds
all right or as he goes
oh there's another dude oh i got him
do you i will in a second
he's about to eat a nade and i'm about
to extract his [ __ ] go go go go go go go
go
all right
i killed him i killed him killed him all
right
i'm gonna john cena him do it dora can't
see me
oh he gave up all right let's run let's
start with this
library library
library
damn right um damn right my package is
secure i'm getting shot at are you yep
you need me to loop around for you um
nope
is it just straight
yeah dude
yeah we
kind of uh panicked last time it's just
straight
like i'm yeah
oh man there's a lot of red pings to my
left i don't like it
93 seconds
i kind of want to get them here oh but
nothing i'm getting shot at are you yeah
do you give me a turn
no
one of those heat moments where i turn
around and like i'm [ __ ] bust a cab
is it here i appreciate it but i am here
is it straight it's right it's totally
it okay we're totally on point
i think these guys will be chasing us
though yeah yeah
i dare them me too i want that to happen
i do too
uh are you watching are we are we doing
the same same positions i'll get this
one this time okay okay okay
oh no you get this one
okay
you got to make these things clear but
if they're behind me the stream is
watching you i want to make sure oh
that's right what if they what if they
oh are you gonna call are they gonna
come around watch that watch that watch
that backside okay i will
we gotta last 30 seconds oh you're just
gonna leave me open like this can they
get up from there can they get up from
that back side
i don't know i mean i'll check both just
be careful
careful is my middle name okay
uh i don't think
no what are those red beacons are those
just uh enemy ai near the library it
might be enemy ai near the library oh
you know what i mean yeah or like
someone was chasing us and maybe engage
those guys oh we're good we're good
we're good yeah
i really want them to come up i want to
see this they're not going to come up
here you're crazy are you calling it 16
seconds oh wait i have it longer i guess
oh you do okay
maybe i can maybe i can
aggravate one of them and then they'll
uh
you know
yeah how long do you have two seconds
okay we're good we're good oh okay here
you want to kill the ai these uh the
library ai level eights sure i think
they're here
oh or should we go to this extract
oh let's see party because i'm on a
rogue high right now
i don't even know if we'll make it
24 seconds
that was quick
why was that so quick
because it's been called in why is there
no but like it's supposed to be like
what like oh there's dudes here then it
has dudes here though all right well
let's go
but you know what i mean why
has it
was i not paying attention i feel like
it just went to 30. i don't know
yeah rank 6.
oh really he didn't like it yeah oh poor
guy there's a lot of f words coming out
of these guys they're not they're not
feeling it
in the chat i don't know bad guys oh i
thought you meant to check yeah right
chad's digging the rogue action rogue
live
he got alex he said it dude i told you
man i hear it all the time there was one
time where like
it just was just right after the other
he got alex
it's like all right like why alex can it
just been like they got him
oh he said man down that time
it's just like they only got one name
and it's alex oh shoot his foot
punch up
damn it
you got him
you got him
damn it
uh we can try to find the next
extraction
yeah let's do that
all right i mean i really wanna heal
some ai
real quick what more ai i think it's
just more guys in the zones
yeah so i feel like well yeah
gunfire maybe we can just go rogue on
someone and then run okay
uh as long as he's got luke as long as
he's packing
all right let's see where is the closest
extraction i'm gonna mark the closest
extraction but i don't think that
they've shot a flare out
they will
all the gunfire is behind at least
coming from behind from what i can tell
yeah we haven't been to this one in a
while
isn't this this uh sports store
uh oh someone just started an extraction
right here is it here yeah yeah it
totally is
where you wanna go you wanna go from the
rope yep i can taste the loot already
yeah
hey guys i got loot too oh there's
actually loot here oh do you see it
earlier yeah yeah is this the spot
though no no this is not the spot oh
oh damn do we want to go back there dude
what's up
oh you got a three piece
dude special
oh there's a blue here oh okay go ahead
take it it's a trekking jacket but i
love my jacket do you yeah i don't know
if i like my jacket do i like my jacket
let me see
so this is another thing if you guys
didn't know ooh uh let's see a simple
jacket nah
i got some cross terrain boots
cause you can really oh man we lost too
much time talking there
well that thing's too far away
all right what do you want to do you
want to call it in and maybe people come
after us
yeah we can do that
oh there's totally bad guys here by the
way
like ai i just scared him by shooting
off that player
hey tell you what
uh i won't
i won't extract my [ __ ] so then
i'll do an uh i'll extract right after
you
okay so we'll get potentially more
candidates for rogue
if you catch my drift well i do you know
i can't see this guy
and this guy apparently is over here
somewhere
oh there's a guy coming up
on your position
like a friendly
uh currently friendly friendly
all right well the call is behind this
barrier i don't like this guy
he looked at me
oh he's got loot too though dude behind
you bro oh you're lagging
i'm lagging
oh that guy yeah i know i saw that
oh [ __ ]
oh you're good right oh yeah there's
totally a guy with the bat on you yep
nice yeah he uh i got you i got showed
how it worked on my head
i haven't played this game a while i
forgot b is like mandolin [ __ ]
more loot what we got here
oh
i'm so dead
do you have heal by the way i do i'm
sorry if you didn't think i did i
totally do you yeah thank you
all right i'm just gonna do it too yeah
why don't we just kill that guy he has
loot right yeah where's he at
oh ready bring it on board
oh he's down oh he's down yeah should i
just kill him no just let him die out
let him bleed out
i'll revive him and then we'll kill him
why you could just kill him right now no
now we'll kill him all right fine
do it
he's not dying
from lag or something
there he's down now oh another guy here
yeah
i'm killing him
oh all he had was a trendy jacket
shoot him though oh sorry i thought that
was you
he doesn't have [ __ ] doesn't matter
we're rogue already good point
member of your team to survive the
division
all right uh what do you wanna do you
wanna hang out i could call i could call
it
call it then let's do it like should i
call it and then
we'll just kill people can you even call
it when you're rogue
yeah i can do it then all right [ __ ] it
party
thing is i think ai's gonna come too
though
that could be a problem
on your position
oh yeah i like that spot
god that's smart
i heard it can't hide forever
oh they must be down there
so far away
where'd you put it oh
yeah
i forgot about this perch here
oh who just shot at us
hey remember when you're over there and
you're invisible oh yeah and i was
shooting these guys yeah good times
oh what was that
oh
where are they shooting us from though
oh they're shooting are they shooting
from across the world oh my god they are
they're shooting from the sports store
oh they're actually guys in there huh
yeah no joke
this is real ballsy of us by the way
steel loot and then extract it in the
same spot thinking those guys won't come
back
you know
you got to live life
and
everyone has their own path
we've just gotten the rogue path yeah
and you know this is how this is how
criminals like go down right they get
they get too greedy on life because
we've had we've had such great success
and uh if we're going to go down i want
to throw it out go down rogan
uh i don't see anyone this guy here i'm
gonna go
you don't have i do i do have one okay i
do have like one thing
yeah i hope someone comes
does
um i know that when you and we got money
for surviving i know that when you uh
and your stash was full it told you
right when you're expected yeah it did
which kind of sucks though because it's
like whoa
how was i supposed to know it's full
like i got all these blues right like
15 seconds are we going to that store i
guess then or what yeah let's go the
store i want to see more of that
i'm just getting so bored of killing
people
that's the fastest way down there this
rope right where's this real bad there's
a rope in the back too really
complete
thanks om dahani he said he likes eric
and rob
thank you
this is not a game for story we don't
know that actually it could be really
dark we haven't seen that much a story
a little bit but i thought
oh you're lagging out look at that or
for me at least yeah it'll catch up cast
maybe we did that last time too right
yeah
oh there you go
whoa this is so weird oh there's a
random
dude that just hit me with a golf club
he does not care about my
dude i don't
what's up
do you not see me oh no you do damn dude
it's like it's literally like it's a
it's a
oh crap i just missed with the heel
i guess now it's caught up that was so
weird it's just like a complete like
five second delay of what i'm looking at
your screen and whatever you're doing
five seconds later i see
that's weird
all right this is gonna get hot yep
that's how i like it
what was that
i'm scared i heard something get shot at
here we go oh there's totally dudes in
here
don't forget your um oh yeah thanks you
completely uh forgot remind me oh i just
had a really bad throw on it
oh god i just took so oh
no
oh there's no escape i didn't have an
escape either dude
i got stuck in a wall
no there's a grenade on you and on me oh
that was two grenades oh so i jumped
literally into yours i jumped into yours
ah
sorry dude this one was really hard last
time are you guys safe
yeah safe room's fine
hey that felt like karma
as long as we didn't have loot i'm cool
oh it's true
damn all right let's go clear that out
and
see if we get we're going to clear it
out okay
we're going to um extract that loot okay
and then if anyone comes around our way
we're going to smoke them cool and then
we'll send that out
we'll call it a stream i like that
the ai knew they pinched pinched us with
double nades that was pretty dirty well
it's just that you want to do a
different entrance because i know
there's different ways yeah there is
there's you can let's do that what is
this extraction going on that though
oh can we make that
do you know we can make that i
if you see it yeah i don't see an
extraction it's over there it's to your
right
oh
what time we got on that thing oh [ __ ]
there's a minute we could we could
probably
we could probably make it if we ran
right now
just run past these guys
all right just run past the rest of them
oh you took a lot of damage uh let's
just use normal heels
serpentine i am captain america oh you
just damn it here i go
oh did that get you yeah yeah oh
i'm taking hits you're taking hits from
behind don't worry
uh beta should be open for anyone that
has like xbox live or uh
playstation plus um it's not out yet for
playstation it's only on xbox one today
uh but later on i think at like 1am ish
don't quote me on that but i think
around 1am uh ps4 and pc will also
become available
and uh as long as you have a channel oh
that guy has loot oh these guys are
glued
this is our time five seconds oh my god
we gotta hurry we gotta we gotta go i
know just get right into it we gotta
throw needs party on i'm gonna throw a
nade right on top of this point
i don't care how many guys there are
suck it
party on
dude there's so many guys why are you
over there
bro you are in such a bad spot go go go
oh there's so many blues over there [ __ ]
okay i'm running okay okay all right all
right i see you meet you at the library
oh i'm getting [ __ ] up
oh dude they're all over us
okay let's go let's go where are we
going that corner that corner we're
gonna fight from this corner all right
we're gonna fight from this corner oh no
i didn't know it was a blue it's fine
this is the alamo we're gonna we're
gonna
oh we're gonna have our last stand here
you and me all right you and me we're
gonna go out the way we live
oh you better not
yeah you better back up industry oh he
threw a turk
damn that did not kill the turret
oh that's a flash and i am so
all right
oh i got one down though are you okay
yep
another need
oh it's incendiary
oh this is so bad
oh he threw one there [ __ ] you
oh i'm so i'm so dead
wait don't move don't move
oh
oh you're a beast
i believe in you
let's die together
goodbye my love
dude we lost i lost 798 dollars oh my
god dude
whatever dude
that was so worth it killing that many
oh my god yeah we need to loop around oh
my god well that was my bad no no no
it's that was good we're going down that
path oh my god we downed so many dudes
that was doubled
funniest thing oh
man that's a highlight in itself cheers
guys
cheers to dying
going rogue
going out
proper
oh my god i want to see the highlight of
that that was pretty amazing so funny
dude i'm just going up there with like
three or four guys like i was just
punching everyone i'm surprised you
lived through that i was like you're
crazy for going out there to try to like
melee those three guys [ __ ]
you know what to be honest
like the whole idea of going rogue i
like really didn't like when this game
first came out yeah but you know what
it's it works when you're in groups you
definitely don't want to go rogue by
yourself there's like of course not and
we'll play this game by you know by
yourself is going to be shitty because
people like this
mess it up
that's what the single player is for but
um that's a taste of the open beta uh we
went over some of the stuff that was
different
again it is out for xbox one now so if
you have an xbox one xbox live account
you can download it and play it it says
26 27 gigs it's pretty big though oh
really yeah and then uh ps4 pc
uh
i'm guessing one am friday which will be
tonight and tomorrow uh thank you guys
so much for watching um
yeah that was pretty fun rob pretty fun
thank you for that
thanks for joining me you know what i
think our last stream i don't know how
well we did rogue wise but uh up until
that death
this that was great we did pretty well
we had that library figured out yeah if
we had a little bit like we were we had
more time to plan those other ones out
today like that one was like oh crap
they're totally like getting their stuff
out let's just nade all of them yeah i
was more panic and the exit strategy was
bad because i
anyways thank you guys for watching um
stay tuned to more uh livestreams i
think danny's doing something tomorrow
morning danny is streaming far cry
primal tomorrow 9 a.m i believe is the
time 9 a.m pacific standard time so look
forward to that if you guys are awake
for that um if not there will definitely
be a vod or anything something like that
there will be a vod of this as well but
thank you guys for watching um and stay
check us out later thanks
you